small detour i don't know if you think
about this
in into the world of computer science
there's uh
douglas house that or i think came up
with a
name of quine which are i don't know if
you're familiar with these things but
it's computer programs
that have uh i guess exxon and intron
and they copy the whole purpose of the
program is to copy itself
so it prints copies of itself but can
also carry information inside of it
so it's a very kind of crude fun
exercise
of um can we sort of replicate these
ideas from cells
of can we have a computer program that
when you run it
it just prints itself the entirety of
itself
and does it in different programming
languages and so on i've been playing
around and
writing them it's a kind of fun little
exercise you know when i was a kid so so
you know
it it was essentially one of the
of the sort of main stages
in in uh informatics olympiads
that you have to reach in order to be
any so good
yeah is you should be able to write
a program that replicates itself and so
the tax then becomes even you know sort
of more complicated so what is the
shortest
what is the sure program yeah and of
course it's it's you know it's a
function of a programming language
but yeah i i remember you know long long
long time ago
when we tried to you know to to make it
short and short and find the the
the shortcut it's actually on a stack
exchange there's a
entire site called code golf i think
where the entirety is just a competition
people just come up with
whatever task i don't know like uh
write code that reports the weather
today
and the competition is about whatever
programming language what is the
shortest program
and it makes you actually people should
check it out because it makes you
realize there's some
some weird programming languages out
there but
you know just to dig on that a little uh
deeper uh do you think
you know in computer science we don't
often think about
programs just like the machine learning
world now
that's still kind of basic programs
and then there's humans that replicate
themselves right
and there's these mutations and so on
do you think we'll ever have a world
where there's programs that kind of
have an evolutionary process so i'm not
talking about evolutionary algorithms
but i'm talking about programs that kind
of
mate with each other and evolve and like
on their own replicate themselves so
this is kind of
the idea here is
you know that's how you can have a
runaway thing so we think about machine
learning
as a system that gets smarter and
smarter and smarter and smarter at least
the machine learning systems of today
are like it's it's a program that you
can like
turn off as opposed to throwing a bunch
of
little programs out there and letting
them like multiply
and mate and evolve and replicate do you
ever
think about that kind of world you know
when we jump from the biological
systems that uh you're looking at to to
artificial ones i mean it's
almost like you you take the the sort of
the area of intelligent agents
right which are essentially the the
independent sort of
uh codes that run and interact and
exchange the information
right so i i don't see why not i mean i
you know it could be sort of a natural
evolution in in
in this you know uh area of computer
science
i think it's kind of an interesting
possibility it's terrifying too
but i think it's a really powerful tool
like to have like agents
that inter you know we have social
networks with millions of people and
they interact
i think it's interesting to inject into
that was already injected into that bots
right but those bots are pretty dumb uh
uh
you know they're they're probably pretty
dumb algorithms
uh you know it's interesting to think
that
there might be bots that evolve together
with humans and there's the sea of
humans
and robots that are operating first in
the digital space
and you can also think i love the idea
some people worked i think
at harvard at penn there's uh
robotics labs that you know built
take as a fundamental task to build a
robot that given
extra resources can build another copy
of itself
like in the physical space which is uh
super
difficult to do but super interesting as
i remember there's like research on
robots that can build a bridge so they
make a copy of themselves and they
connect themselves and yeah
it's sort of like self-building bridge
based on building
blocks you can imagine like a building
that self-assembles
so it's basically self-assembling
structures from uh
from uh robotic parts but it's
interesting
to within that robot add the ability to
mutate
and uh and and do all the interesting
like little things that you're referring
to in evolution to go from a single
origin protein building block to like
well weird complexity and if you think
about this i mean you know the bits and
pieces
are there you know so so you mentioned
revolutionary algorithm right you know
so this
is sort of yeah and the the maybe sort
of the
the the goal is in a way different right
so the goal is to you know to
essentially
uh to to optimize your search right so
uh but uh sort of the the ideas are
there so you people recognize that you
know that the
the you know recombination events
lead to global changes in the in in its
search trajectories the mutations event
is a more refined
uh you know uh step in in the search
then you have you know uh other sort of
uh nature inspired algorithm right so
one of the reasons that
that they you know i think it's it's one
of the funnest one is the slime
uh based algorithm right so that it's a
i think the first was introduced by the
japanese
group but where it was able to to solve
uh some some pre you know complex
problems
uh so so that's the yeah and and then
i think uh there are still
a lot of things we've yet to to
you know borrow from the nature right so
there are
a lot of sort of ideas that nature
uh you know gets to offer us that
you know it's up to us to grab it and to
to
to you know get the best use of it
including neural networks
you know we have a very crude inspire
inspiration from nature on neural
networks maybe there's
other inspirations to be discovered in
the brain or
other aspects of the various systems
even like the immune system the way it
uh interplays
i recently started to understand that
like the immune system has something to
do with the way the brain
operates like there's multiple things
going on in there
which uh all of which are not modeled in
artificial neural networks
and maybe if you throw a little bit of
that biological spice in there
you'll come up with something uh
something cool
you